[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 140 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
I'm Mandel.
And I'm here, as always, with
my colleague, Melanie Warrick.
Hey, Melanie, how are you doing?
MELANIE WARRICK: Hey, Mark.
I'm doing good.
I survived Next.
How about you?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's
the Monday after Next.
Still getting over it.
It was a big event
with lots of people,
but it was pretty amazing.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Lots of recordings.
We also recorded 17
interviews during Next.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, my.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, 17.
MARK MANDEL: That's a lot.
MELANIE WARRICK: It is a lot.
MARK MANDEL: It's a lot.
MELANIE WARRICK:
But it was good.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: It was.
And we will be sharing a
lot of these interviews
over the next couple of months.
And one of those
actually being this week.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
So who are we talking to today?
MELANIE WARRICK: We're talking
to Maya Kaczorowski, who
is here to talk to us about
container security today.
And we're doing this interview
specifically because next week
will be DEF CON, the big
brouhaha over in Vegas
for all the security stuff.
DEF CON, Black Hat,
BSides, Diana Initiative.
There's all kinds of
stuff that's happening.
And that's all week next week.
And so we thought,
let's kick off prior
to that with a little
bit of information
around container security.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
great interview.
MELANIE WARRICK: But before
we do that, as always,
we have our cool
things of the week.
And we're going to end with
the question of the week.
And this week's
question Maya also
helped give this
to us, which is,
how do I set up SSL
termination on Kubernetes
with Let's Encrypt?
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
So we'll be looking into that.
MELANIE WARRICK:
But Mark, what are
our cool things of the week?
MARK MANDEL: Oh, my God.
There are so many cool
things of the week.
We just had Next.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
We talked about all
these last week, right?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we did.
So rather than trying to
go through all of them,
I'm just going to link to the
blog post that is "What a week!
105 announcements from
Google Cloud Next '18."
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
a lot of announcements.
MARK MANDEL: That's a
lot of announcements.
It's a good article.
It goes through customers,
partnerships, Chrome stuff, AI
and machine learning on Google
Cloud, infrastructure services,
application development, data
analytics services, databases,
IoT, security, G Suite stuff,
some social impact stuff
as well, and finally,
the 105th announcement
being that Next 2019 will be
April 9 through 11 next year.
MELANIE WARRICK: So we
have less than a year
to get ready for that one.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
basically by the time
you read this article
and go through all
the new announcements,
it will be ready
for you to go to Next next year.
MELANIE WARRICK: Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's a good one.
MELANIE WARRICK:
We also have links
to the keynotes, keynote
fireside chats, and spotlight
sessions.
These are all videos
that are on YouTube.
We also have the links to all
sessions for Google Cloud Next
'18, again, also on YouTube.
So you can check out
any of the videos
about the different
sessions that took place.
There were several sessions.
I said-- I think, Mark,
you said at one point
it was almost around 500.
MARK MANDEL: It's
something like that.
I should actually go confirm it.
But yeah, I think
it's about that many.
And then we also wanted to
highlight real quick just
from all the people
we talked to,
I know two things
in particular are
coming to mind that I feel like
I heard people very excited
about those.
Those were GKE On-Prem.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: And Edge TPUs.
So not to say there aren't
many, many announcements
to be excited about.
Just those are ones that
commonly bubbled up to the top
when we were talking to
different participants.
MARK MANDEL: And actually I'll
make it a highlight as well.
If you go into the Keynotes,
Keynote Fireside Chats,
and Spotlight Sessions
playlist, there's
a really great
five-minute synopses
of the keynotes themselves.
So if you don't want to sit
around and watch the whole
thing for an hour-- they are
great, so you can do that--
if you just want a
quick summarization,
there are some really great
little short videos in there
that you can just
have a watch at.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
So Mark, I know we talked
about this last week,
but I wanted to ask.
You've been at Next now
three years in a row.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Before it was called Next.
MELANIE WARRICK: Before
it was called Next.
How did this one
compare to the last two?
MARK MANDEL: It was
definitely a lot bigger.
MELANIE WARRICK: OK.
MARK MANDEL: It was
definitely a lot bigger.
MELANIE WARRICK: OK.
That's an easy answer.
MARK MANDEL: And
it's interesting.
I feel like when
I first started,
we were doing events for
the Google Cloud Platform
at the time.
Before it was called Next, I
think it was called GCP Live.
I'll actually have
to go back and look.
I mean, it was small.
It was really small;
a few hundred people.
I remember teaching
Codelabs in a basement.
That was sort of the first
thing we did way back
about three years ago.
And then from there, we
went to the Pier Building,
where there were
several thousand people,
to Moscone last year.
So it was about 10,000.
This year, another 100%, right?
20,000, 25,000 people.
It's kind of amazing
and kind of impressive,
the amount of
investment that's gone
into Google Cloud as a whole
over the last three years.
But yeah, I think
this year was great.
I had an absolute blast.
It was great to see everyone.
The only thing with
it being so big
is that I didn't get to spend
as much time with as many people
as I wanted to.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: But
still, it was pretty--
it was an amazing event,
like really amazing.
MELANIE WARRICK: It was very
difficult to take in all
the things that were happening.
That's for sure.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: But
it was wonderful,
what we were able to experience.
One other cool thing of the week
that I want to mention that's
not Next related, that we
didn't mention last week.
We have a habit of not
necessarily announcing
certain things on the
actual show itself
and just talking
about it on Twitter.
But we have a new website.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
It's really nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: We have
an update to our website.
We did this two weeks ago.
It's like when we
hit the million mark
and we forgot to mention
it on the actual show.
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
MELANIE WARRICK: So we did
an update to the website.
If you haven't seen it, it's
all beautiful, new look.
Please check it out.
Let us know what you think
and if anything is broken.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: So we
can make sure it's fixed.
But yeah, a new website.
MARK MANDEL: We
soft launched it.
That's why we
didn't tell anybody.
That's why.
MELANIE WARRICK: Soft launch.
I know.
MARK MANDEL: It
was a soft launch.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it was a soft launch.
This is the hard launch.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Is that what it is?
OK.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: It
sounds like a plan.
MARK MANDEL: Anyway.
MELANIE WARRICK: We were
testing it all throughout Next,
which seemed like a good idea.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
Why don't we go check with Maya?
MELANIE WARRICK: I think
that's a great idea.
MARK MANDEL: So we're
super excited to have Maya
Kaczorowski joining us today.
Product manager
container security,
Google Cloud joining us
here on the Next show floor.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Thanks
so much for having me.
Yeah, it's great.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you
so much for joining us.
It's so great to have you here.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, we wanted
to definitely talk to you,
because we've got
a-- well, we're
going to be releasing
this the week after Next.
And we've got a reason for that,
which is the fact that there's
DEF CON coming up
the week after that,
which we'll get into a
little bit more later on.
MARK MANDEL: Wait.
So is this the week after
next or the week after Next?
MELANIE WARRICK:
The week after Next.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Cool.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Can you imagine
being how security people are
so stressed out right now?
They're like, I
have to be at Next.
Then I get to work
for like five days.
And then I have to go to Vegas.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's actually
funny that this is stressful.
Anyways, so Maya, I guess, let's
start out with, who are you?
What do you do?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Yeah, I'm a
product manager on the security
team of Google Cloud.
I've been at Google
for almost three years.
Part of that I was a
management consultant,
did some work in security
for large health care,
financial insurance companies.
And at Google, I was
the PM for Cloud KMS
until about nine months ago.
Then I transitioned over
to container security.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool.
OK.
What's container security?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Yeah,
that's a great question.
Let's start with like,
do we assume people
know what a container is?
Is that a fair assumption?
MARK MANDEL: Let's go there.
Yeah, high level.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great question.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, why
don't we start there?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: OK.
So a container is a
simpler way of packaging
some of your software up
to make it more portable
and do better bin
packing on your computer.
So rather than having a VM,
which is somebody else's
or your hardware, and
you just kind of care
about the OS, a container you
care about even less than that.
You just package the application
with binaries and libraries
into a container.
And then you can run
it on a minimal OS
that can be kind of arbitrary
and anywhere environments.
The idea being you can move
this thing around really easily,
but it's kind of hard to
manage these things at scale,
which is what Google learned
more than a decade ago
internally.
And so internally, we created
Borg a long, long time ago
and externally created
Kubernetes about four years ago
now.
And Kubernetes is a way for
you to-- it's a container
orchestration platform.
It's a way for you
to manage containers
in terms of right-sizing them,
scaling things up and down,
load balancing, et cetera,
groups of containers.
So container security--
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
Yes, that.
MARK MANDEL: I will
make a small segue.
Episode 46, we did an episode
on Borg with John Wilkes.
So if you want to
learn more about Borg,
you can go back and hear about
the history of Kubernetes.
Anyway, please continue.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Awesome.
So we're thinking about
container security at Google
in three main pillars,
or three main areas.
The first one is what we'll
call infrastructure security.
So making sure that
your containers
are secure to develop.
So this is around configurations
you're putting into Kubernetes
or Kubernetes Engine--
things like seeker management,
networking, identity and access
management, et cetera.
All these things that you need
to have in your infrastructure
for this thing to work.
The second area is what we're
calling software supply chain
or making sure that your
containers are secure for--
your container images are
secure to build and deploy.
So how do you know
that your images
are free of vulnerabilities?
How do you know what the
dependencies that you have are,
that it came out of your
build pipeline, et cetera,
before you deploy them?
And then the third area is what
we're calling container runtime
security, or making sure
that your containers are
secure at runtime.
And this is around making sure--
it's traditional
security operations.
So if somebody attacks
your container,
if you have an attempted
container escape, et cetera,
how do you identify
that, mitigate it?
Can you could do
forensics after the fact
to see what actually
happened in your environment
and then track that?
MELANIE WARRICK: So what
is different about securing
containers compared to VMs?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Sure.
I mean, at a high level,
not a lot in the sense
that I think security people are
very worried about this model.
We're like, ah, I don't know
what these containers are.
I don't know what Kubernetes is.
I don't want to have to
learn all this new stuff.
It's not that bad.
If you had a network
firewall before,
you still need a
network firewall.
If you had an IDS IPS
before, you still need one.
You still need
identity management.
seeker management.
All these things are the same.
The plugability points
a little bit different.
I think some of the
main differences,
though, are one is this minimal
OS, as I mentioned earlier.
Compared to a VM, you can have
a much smaller host operating
system than you do
on a virtual machine.
And what that means is
if you're doing it right,
that thing is tiny and you
patch that super regularly.
It shouldn't have
any vulnerabilities
that somebody can exploit.
And that actually makes
your overall system safer,
because you have smaller
surface of attack.
Another major difference between
containers and VMs is, I think,
one of the talking points
against containers,
as people were saying, hey, I
don't have as good isolation
with containers.
I don't have this
hypervisor, which
I have with VMs, that provides
strong isolation, security
isolation between my systems.
And that was sort of true
until Google released
gVisor and these other
projects in the open source,
like Kata containers and
Nabla containers that
provide container-level
or actually pod-level,
in Kubernetes, isolation.
So one of the counterarguments
against using containers
from a security point of view
is now one of its strengths.
You can use the same strong
isolation at a container level
and still have the bin
packing and the benefits
of using containers
that you were
aiming for in the first place.
MARK MANDEL: Does
that mean that we
should be running all our
containers under something
like gVisor?
Or is it fine what
we're doing now?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
That's a great question.
I think gVisor is meant to be
a most-purpose sandbox, not
an all-purpose sandbox.
So gVisor filters
about 150 comments as
calls, and prevents a
process from running things
that it shouldn't run.
It's not going to be perfect for
every single application you're
going to want to run
in your environment.
That being said, we use
gVisor internally at Google
to run some of our services.
And I'll also kind of answer
not a question that you asked.
You said, should I run all
my containers in gVisor?
I'll say, should you run all
your things on containers?
What a great question, Mark!
Not necessarily, but that's
certainly Google's model.
Some of the reasons we can
do things like live migration
is because we have Borg.
So we have these whole
packages of things,
including your containers which
run inside of our containers,
and we can move them around
easily and patch the underlying
infrastructure without
taking you down.
And that's the beauty of using
something like containers.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Actually, on a side note,
I'm curious, what would
you not run on containers?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
I think anything
that has specific hardware
dependencies I would probably
not attempt to do
right now at least.
So if you have some very, very
custom stuff on bare metal
on-prem, like it's OK, like not
the first workload I'd go for.
And then the other
end of the spectrum
is the functions, right?
Something that's super simple
that it's too heavyweight
to spin up a container.
Don't bother.
MARK MANDEL: So actually,
I was going to follow up
and say, is it also possibly
a question of what trust
you have in the software
that you're running?
If you're like,
this is my software.
I know where it came from.
And I know what it's doing.
So I'm like, that's OK.
But if I don't know where
the software is coming from,
then maybe that's something I'd
put inside gVisor or something
like that.
Would that be fair?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
That's a great point.
So we think about software
and the level of trust
that it has as a continuum.
Nothing is fully trusted.
Nothing is fully untrusted.
This is very security
person messaging.
But more trusted software might
be software that you build,
might be software that your
developers have signed,
et cetera, that's
from you internally.
And yeah, you're probably
OK running one developer's
software from your company
next to another developer's
software.
And that's fine, short
of some insider risk.
On the other on the
spectrum, you're
running some third-party
arbitrary code,
some plug-in that you downloaded
from GitHub that you don't
really know what's in there.
We have some customers who
are running their customers
provided data in containers.
And in that particular
case, I would be worried.
Not so much about
a container escape,
but like around one workload
affecting another workload
in terms of resource use.
MARK MANDEL: So
actually-- and I think you
alluded to this before as well.
Are there are tools that we
can use for container security
so that we know, hey, this
came from developers, or hey,
this is actually the thing
that I was meant to download,
and I downloaded it.
And it wasn't a problem
in somewhere between.
And stuff like that.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Yeah.
So typically when you're
setting up your environment,
you're going to have a
container registry of some kind.
You're going to have somewhere
you put all your images.
And Google offers what is called
Google Container Registry.
We're great at naming.
And it integrates with GKE.
And the idea being you store all
the stuff that you want there.
You can check things like, did
this go through QA and testing,
all of that before deploying.
What we actually just
announced at Next
is binary authorization.
So binary authorization
is a way for you
to enforce that the container
images that you deploy
are those that you authorize,
that came out of your pipeline.
So the main use case
we're going for here
is, I have a build pipeline.
I'm using CircleCI,
[INAUDIBLE],, Jenkins,
whatever happens to be.
And I give that thing
a private sign-in key.
It signs that it did in
fact build that image.
And then I have it an emission
controller that enforces,
did that signature exist on
the image before I deployed?
And if the signature does not
exist, it will not be deployed.
So that's called
binary authorization.
Some other cases you can imagine
around that are things like,
hey, I don't want to
deploy images that
have known vulnerabilities.
I only want to
deploy images that
came out of my particular
repository, et cetera.
So you can think about that
type of policy management
in that space.
MELANIE WARRICK: You were
saying before about gVisor.
Where would that play a role
in the way this is built out?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Yeah, I think gVisor
is a great tool for anytime
you have untrusted workloads
that you want to try bin
pack closer together.
And then if you also have
even trusted workloads
that you think they are still
going to work fine, like to me,
that seems like
a no regret move.
Why wouldn't you want to
do a little bit more work
and get a lot more security?
MELANIE WARRICK: Under the
three areas that you mentioned
in terms of security, one
question that comes to mind
is, what's the hardest to be
able to secure for containers?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: I think we're
seeing people kind of shift
from left to right,
in that the first one
being infrastructure, then
software supply chain, and then
container runtime.
A lot of developers are
still focused right now on,
how do I make Kubernetes secure
and what are the best practices
I follow there?
And where we're sort of
failing as a community
is that it's so
hard for a developer
to understand what
they need to do.
What I mean by that is--
I mentioned I started working
in container security about nine
months ago.
I thought it would take
me like a month or two
to figure out what
was going on in space.
And I'd be like, yeah, yeah.
And then I've got container
security figured out.
It'll be fine.
And it probably took
me four or five months
to sort of get a good
handle on what was going on.
And I was like, oh, man,
I'm getting old and tired.
And why is this
taking me so long?
I'm not as good as I used to be.
This is terrible.
MELANIE WARRICK: No imposter
syndrome going on there at all.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: That's
not common at Google at all.
What are you talking about?
And then I went to KubeCon
in Copenhagen this past May.
And at that point in time, I
had a pretty good understanding
of what was going on.
And so many people came up
to me and said, how do I
set up a network policy?
What is RBAC and
should I use that?
And these are-- to me,
these are like the basics
in container security
and Kubernetes security.
And it kind of hit me.
It was like, oh, my God.
This is way too
complicated for anyone.
MARK MANDEL: Right.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
And so the challenge
I think we have right
now is not so much that--
sure, there are areas that the
tooling doesn't even exist yet,
or we haven't figured out
how to solve the problem yet,
but the stuff that we
have built is pretty hard
to use for an average
developer, or the defaults
that are there aren't great
for the average developer yet.
So there's a lot being done in
Kubernetes and the open source
to improve that.
But if you're starting
off from scratch,
you can google Hardening
Guide and you'll
find lots of different
people's opinions
as to what you should do.
MARK MANDEL: So what are your
opinions on best practices?
Both probably on the container
side and on the Kubernetes side
as well.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: On
the Kubernetes side,
there's a piece of
documentation on the GKE site,
g.co/GKE/hardening, which
is our Hardening Guide.
And it goes through what is
hardened for you already in GKE
and what else you need to do.
Some really basics are, hey,
you should probably use RBAC.
If you're using
Kubernetes Engine,
use IAM at the project
level, and then use
RBAC at the cluster
and namespace level.
Set up a network policy so
pods can talk to each other
by default within the cluster.
That's great if
you're developing.
That's terrible if you're
having supersensitive workload
running next to each
other in the same cluster.
And then from there,
just some things
like setting a seccomp
profile is a great choice.
You can enable that using
pod security policy.
It provides a pretty
strong security default
for your containers.
MARK MANDEL: Can you explain
what a seccomp profile is?
Because I have vaguely an idea.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Yeah, a seccomp profile
is a-- seccomp is
secure computing mode.
And it puts your container sort
of like in a one-way secure
state-- and I'm doing
air quotes here--
where it can run a
certain set of syscalls.
And if it tries to run things
like secreturn and exit,
if it tries to run any
other set of syscalls,
then it will be terminated.
So it's preventing
your container
from potentially running
something that would be unsafe.
There's a pretty good
default out there.
It's the Docker seccomp profile.
It blocks about 150 uncommon
or barely used syscalls.
And that should probably
work for your application,
but test it out, obviously,
before you deploy it at scale.
MELANIE WARRICK: And I know
you've mentioned RBAC before,
but I don't know what RBAC is.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Oh, sorry.
RBAC is Role-Based
Access Control.
It's a way of thinking
about policy management.
It's a generic term for thinking
In Kubernetes specifically,
it's how you bind the access
to certain resources, like pods
or deployments or namespaces
to individual users.
And so you create a role
that has a set of permissions
on a particular resource.
For example, I
can read this pod,
and then you would bind that
between the role to a user.
The idea then you can
change the bindings.
So if somebody quits
their job tomorrow,
rather than removing
individual permissions,
you just remove the
role, and then they've
lost those permissions.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
Do you have any tools that
you'd recommend for people
to use to automate
security in the space?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: I
see a lot of people
using some sort of
templating language.
So Terraform is pretty
popular, or Helm.
That's typically the
choice people go with.
MARK MANDEL: Is there any
sort of automated tools
for just making sure there
are no vulnerabilities
in my containers?
Is that a thing?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Yeah, so you're
probably going to look at
vulnerabilities in your images,
because what's pretty cool
about containers versus VMs
and things is that rather than
changing single lines of code,
you actually change
that line of code,
but then you redeploy
the whole container.
So you have this
enforcement point,
which is your deployment point,
where you see everything that
ends up in your infrastructure.
So actually what that means is
you get this very powerful way
of patching your infra,
which is that if you just
patch your images
on a regular basis,
you can kind of passively
deploy the patch.
As containers die, it'll
grab the latest image
and get redeployed, which
is amazing, which is,
again, think back
at like how Google
does live migration with Borg.
And like this is why we
can do things like that.
It's genius.
So specifically, how do
you patch your images?
And how do you know what
the vulnerabilities are?
Google just announced
Google Container Registry
vulnerability scanning.
And that looks at the packages
in your images and the images
themselves-- maybe that's a
better way of putting it--
that you have stored in GCR.
We'll scan those automatically
for known vulnerabilities
from the CVE database.
And it'll also rescan
when new vulnerabilities
are found or announced.
And then you can
patch those as needed
and deploy them to
your environment.
MARK MANDEL: Out of
curiosity, how does that work?
Because you've got this
artifact that's an image,
and then how does it
know how to get inside?
I don't know.
That seems crazy,
but interesting.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: You
decompose the different layers
of the image.
So you get all the packages
that are inside them.
And you take a hash
of the packages.
And you compare that
against whether those
are known to have that
vulnerability or not.
Yeah.
So that's not scanning.
Notably, that's not
scanning at the code level.
That's not scanning
things like, hey,
did you leave the keys in code?
Or did you have a
misconfiguration?
Et cetera.
There's a ton of third-party
solutions in that space that
do provide that functionality
if that's something
you want to do.
MELANIE WARRICK: So what's
a software supply chain?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Oh, yeah.
The software supply chain
is that middle piece
that we were talking
about earlier-- so how
we go from developing your code
to having an image to making
sure image is free of
vulnerabilities to checking
that it meets all
your requirements
when it's deployed, and
then to seeing that that
doesn't change over time.
So that's-- one big piece of
that is that vulnerability
scanning piece.
Another big piece of that
is the binary authorization.
Basically, the
announcements that we've
had around Next around
container security
have been in that software
supply chain area.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
know we've already
talked a little bit about
resources, but are there
any additional places people can
go if they wanted to know more,
to get involved,
to do development
in container security?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Sure.
There's a couple
of links that we'll
put somewhere on the site.
They include cloud.google.com
/containers/security.
It's kind of an overview of
how we think about containers
at Google, including
a lot of the items
that I've talked about today.
And then I mentioned
specifically
the Hardening Guide for GKE.
It's another really great
spot if you're using GKE
and want to have further
security than what we already
provide you by default.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, as I
mentioned early in this podcast
that we are going
to be releasing this
the week before the
big brouhaha in Vegas
with Black Hat and
DEF CON and BSides,
can you tell the
audience a little bit
about these conferences
that are coming up
and what this whole
thing looks like?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: So this is
comically sometimes called
like security summer camp.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Since all the security
nerds get together in Vegas.
And it's really hot.
And we don't really sleep.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know
August is not the best
time necessarily to go.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Yeah.
I was there last year.
And I don't even know.
I think I got sick,
because you're
going outside from
like 40 degrees
to like inside it's
like 50-- sorry.
I speak Celsius-- 15 degrees.
MARK MANDEL: I do the same.
It's fine.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
And it's just insane.
So DEF CON and all that stuff.
So there's a Black
Hat conference, which
is a big security conference.
A lot of vendor shows, a lot
of research announcements,
et cetera.
The same time as
Black Hat, there's
BSides Las Vegas, which
is an alternative security
conference.
And then at the end
of the week, there
is DEF CON, which
is probably one
of the more infamous
security conferences,
a lot of live hacking,
zero days that
are dropped as part
of presentations,
that kind of stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: For
those who might not know,
what are zero days?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: A zero
day is a newly-discovered
vulnerability
which is unpatched.
A great example would be
like Spectre and Meltdown.
When those were
announced-- well,
actually, maybe they're
not such a great example,
because Google had patched
them when they were announced.
Heartbleed.
Heartbleed would
be a great example,
where when it was announced,
it was not yet patched
in the public domain.
And so it was immediately
exploitable by an attacker.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah,
we did a nice episode
on Spectre and Meltdown.
I talked a little bit about
why the security decisions are
made in terms of when
to share information
and trying to patch it
at the appropriate times.
But that's great to understand.
And so how many
years now has it been
for you going to these events?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: It will
be my fourth DEF CON.
MELANIE WARRICK: And what
are you most excited about?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: The
Crypto Privacy Village.
I've been quite involved with
that village for a while.
And I'm obviously
an encryption nerd.
And that's the entire village.
It's like getting a couple
of hundred people in a room
together to talk
about encryption.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I was going
to say, what's a village?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
So the main talk
tracks at DEF CON, which are
in these giant convention
halls, thousands of people
in the room, and even those,
some of the best talks
you end up lining up for
and still can't get into.
So villages are
the smaller areas
to have specific conversations
on particular topics.
So for example, last year
they had a voting machine
hacking village, where
some researchers brought in
on the order of 20
or 30 voting machines
and just basically
said, go for it.
We'll write up
everything that you find,
and send them to
some authorities
and see if we can fix some of
the problems that are here,
which is pretty cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: That is cool.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: There's
a wall of sheep, which
is all about packet capture.
If you take your real
phone with you to DEF CON
and have it kind of open
and connected to something
that looks like it might
be a legitimate Wi-Fi,
somebody is probably
just capturing everything
that you're sending
them and then
displaying it on a giant screen
for everybody else to see.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Oh, that's great.
So this is the
hazing that happens.
MARK MANDEL: What
sort of preparation
do you take to go to DEF CON?
Do you take your proper phone?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: I do.
I probably shouldn't.
MARK MANDEL: Well, you
shouldn't say it on a podcast
that you do.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: I used
to take a burner phone.
And I think I got a
little bit complacent.
MARK MANDEL: Right.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: I
do take a Chromebook.
Chromebooks are great for
this kind of scenario, where
it's like, I need
something that I
can wipe if I have
any concern whatsoever
with it being compromised.
But nothing's ever happened
to me at Black Hat or DEF CON.
MELANIE WARRICK: Knock on wood.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Yeah, yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Not an invite.
Well, any tips
for anybody who is
going for the first time
or any of the people
who maybe can't
go, but they want
to learn more at a later date?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Yeah, definitely
go if it's something
you're interested in.
It's a very
accessible conference.
If you're having a bad time or
someone's being mean to you,
go find one of the Goons.
They were these like red shirts.
And they will help you
navigate the conference
and take care of whatever
issue is going on.
I would say go to
some of the villages
and find people
who are like-minded
and find things
you're excited about.
If you're new, the
Lockpick Village
is a great place to
just go hang out.
There's a bunch of tables
with locks you can pick.
MELANIE WARRICK: It sounds fun.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Exactly.
And all the big rooms, all
those talks are recorded.
So if you miss one of those,
it's not really a big deal.
The stuff that's in
person is the stuff
that you're going
to really miss.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
MELANIE WARRICK: It sounds about
right for most conferences.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Exactly.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, great.
MARK MANDEL: I did
want to mention
you have a series of blog posts
on the Google Cloud Platform
blog, too, about container
security that are really great.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: We had a
series of blog posts leading up
to KubeCon in May.
Seven blog posts just
about container security;
one on networking, one on image
security, one on image signing,
one on runtime security,
some of the partners
that we announced in that
space; one on isolation.
Just so many blog posts.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's a
pretty good memory, though.
MARK MANDEL: We'll have
a link in the show notes.
There's a bunch
of stuff in there.
So it's definitely
worth checking out
if you're interested
in this stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Maya,
very much for coming
and joining us today.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Thank
you so much for having me.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
have fun at DEF CON.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Definitely.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you again, Maya,
for coming on the podcast
and sharing with us
about container security
before next week's big security
conference.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it was
really great to have a chat
and have your experience
and have your knowledge come
and join us.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
Well, Mark, how do I set up
SSL termination on Kubernetes
with Let's Encrypt?
MARK MANDEL: So I'm going to
defer to one of our teammates
on it, who is a DPE who
works on Google Cloud.
He has a really great
tutorial on GitHub
for installing an open
source project called
Cert Manager to get HTTPS
certificates from Let's
Encrypt.
If you're not familiar
with Let's Encrypt,
it's basically a
free service that
has programmatic APIs
for getting TLS and SSL
certs, which is pretty awesome.
And it's free.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Which
is kind of amazing.
It is worth noting--
I find this confusing--
I think a lot of
people use Cert Manager
even though Cert
Manager says, hey,
maybe be careful about
using this in production,
because we don't know
if it's ready yet.
But I know a lot of people that
use it, which is kind of fun.
So I give you that
proviso as well.
But the tutorial
also links to things
like Cloudflare and
Backplane, like if you
want to actually pay for a
service that's going to provide
SSL certs for you as well.
So there's a few
different options there.
Yeah, Let's Encrypt
is pretty great.
It's a great place to
get started and get
playing with this stuff.
So we'll link to that
article in the show notes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sounds good.
Mark, are you going to be
anywhere any time soon?
MARK MANDEL: So I
don't know about soon.
End of August, I will be
speaking at PAX Dev talking
about Agones.
I'll be hanging out at PAX West
afterwards with all my gaming
friends.
What about yourself?
What are you up to?
MELANIE WARRICK:
So on August 6, I'm
actually going to be speaking
at the 2018 Nuclear Innovation
Boot Camp at Berkeley.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, fancy.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah,
it does sound fancy.
MARK MANDEL: Are you speaking
about something in particular?
MELANIE WARRICK: AI.
What else would I talk about?
MARK MANDEL: Fair enough.
That sounds reasonable.
MELANIE WARRICK: Or
machine learning.
But yes.
They asked me to come and
speak to the students there.
So that will be fun.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right, Melanie.
Well, thank you so
much for joining me
for yet another
week on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, and welcome
to episode number
140 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
[DOG PANTING]
My dog is coming up here.
And let me try
that one more time.